so now it's my huge way to welcome
samantha morton sam hello
you're very very welcome here we're very
grateful to you for
spending this evening with us um you're
no stranger to bafta
you've won one for the
semi-autobiographical
directorial debut that you did that
unloved um
you've been bafta nominated for several
performances for control
for longford and then for very recently
for i am kirsty
and uh we were very sorry not to be able
to talk to you during the kind of
nominee process well i am kirsty
i'm so glad that we get to talk to you
about it tonight
um we've got uh about a little bit over
an hour we're going to jump
around a little bit because we've got a
huge back catalogue that we can
refer to you've got something like 30
features um
over 20 tv series as an actor plus
several writer credits
plus your award-winning directorial
debut
um we've got all that to mine in order
to get
a little bit of a sense of your
relationship to the roles that you
choose
to the nature of your different
collaborations and to your
techniques as an actor and you can be as
detailed as you want
um i'm gonna kick off with some
questions but it is absolutely
for our audience to ask you questions um
everybody you should just note that you
just click on the q
a box and you write in your questions
and we'll
um i'll try and get to them as we go
through but i'll certainly leave a good
time at the end
to get through to your questions so
let's get to it sam how how
are you where where are you and and
how's your lockdown been
um i'm in the uk which is lovely um
i got back to the uk in november having
just
finished uh shooting the walking dead
the tv series that i
am part of that world um and then kind
of christmas happened and then
you know sadly a global pandemic kind of
kicked in and there was the bit before
the pandemic were all a bit
before lockdown where we kind of knew it
wasn't good and
and then we had locked down and locked
down for me was i was lucky
because i you know i have where i used
to live i had a
you know big garden and it was in the
countryside and
you know really beautiful lovely
community of people
and but ultimately i find i found it
distressing or kind of
personally distressing and you have to
be very strong for your children
you have to be strong for everybody and
and something kicks in in a way whereby
we i suppose survival we we are strong
but
um it wasn't easy at all um and what's
it done
have you been productive during this
time no because
yeah i don't know no i was a bit
but you know when you've got small
children young children
and they're not at school and you're
trying to navigate bbc bite size
and i can i mean i can hardly um
do half the things that my kids do at
school so it was really tricky actually
and trying to make
you know make sure that you're
exercising every day and
you're out and you know we've got
animals and
yeah so it wasn't as productive as
as i think a lot of other people's you
know
i tried to mix it up as much as i could
and
being creative with the children was
really important to me and
and um yeah
all right well we can hear more about
what you've what you've got coming up
um the temptation with these things is
always to do them kind of
chronologically but actually i'd rather
we started
at the very end with the kind of the
thing that you did most recently
um i am kirsty because it's such a great
piece and i really wanted to have a time
to
to talk about it um it was one part of
an anthology series created by
dominic savage and your part also
created by you
tell us what was there at the beginning
like did kirsty
exist um you know how much of a kind of
fleshed out person was she and what did
you
how did you work on her well
dominic uh was auditioning or meeting
actresses in in order to make this he
knew that he wanted to make
uh a series of films uh
you know about women that women had a
huge amount of power in like
what do you want to say and i've been
talking about this
uh to i've been trying to get hold of
various filmmakers uh female filmmakers
actually
in order to tell a version of this story
they never got back to me or they're
like oh just get in touch with my system
and i was like oh okay but i really
wanted to talk to you personally about
this and it was just tricky
and i find it really tricky actually i
was finding it really tricky to get
um things are a bit different now i
think because
everyone's had a lot more time to with
lock down and think about
you know different way of working but
certainly for many years if you would
approach people with a project
it isn't it wasn't easy to get things
off the ground and so it wasn't
i was a bit fed up with that really like
have i think i'd have these
good ideas and i'd kind of approach
people and nothing would really come of
it and i'm like well i'm not a producer
actually i don't know how to produce
um and that's never gonna happen and a
little bit like
thinking back to the unloved is that for
a while there i was trying to get other
people to make that film
um because i i just wanted to step back
i want to step away from it have the
idea and let someone else direct it and
have fresh eyes on that subject matter
that's what i thought all those years
ago
but this was different this was dominic
sitting with me taking the time
to say as an actress what what do you
want to do
and what do you feel is being
underrepresented or what kind of
roles do you think aren't out there for
you and i'm you know i'm 43
and you literally have this situation
where roles just disappear like
all of a sudden you know my 20s you've
got scripts and scripts and scripts and
i was really lucky
and i am really lucky and i feel
privileged about that but it still is
like you just suddenly notice
what roles are coming in and the right
and the a huge amount of male writers
on these projects and what they're
writing about and and what people want i
suppose what people are commissioning
and what they're wanting to be told so
this was like
what stories people want to tell
and you know initially i was like oh
i mean i am a huge fan of dominic and
dominic's work and and i really always
have been and he's one of the ones that
i've
gosh if i was lucky enough to work with
kind of things so i didn't want to
be rude to him or say anything
inappropriate but i was kind of like
well
it's weird kind of you making female
stories because you're a male
you know like what do i mean but
actually
it it became about equality and it
became about the
masculine and the feminine coming
together and this this beautiful
thing of of the facilitation of that
and um so we we talked and talked
for i mean hours and hours about
different ideas and
he had ideas and i had ideas and then
eventually
we came to this this character kirsty
who is in my world an amalgamation of
people i've known incredibly well in my
life
it's an incredibly personal yet again a
personal story
and he he took the if you like the
the seeds of truth and and made it a
story
so i could therefore uh free the
free the trauma if you like and be an
act in it rather than go oh
my you know um and he was amazing and
that's
and he is amazing and that's where that
kind of
i hope that makes sense that's where
definitely kind of
how that happened tell us how the
dynamic shifts between
you as an actor him as a director but
something that you've already written
you've also
written or contributed to very heavily
how does that change things
would you i am kirsky was improvised
fully improvised
from the moment you're on set to the
minute the camera is turned off till
stuart says right camera's turned off
now
you're always in character so
it isn't like writing dialogue it's
about
writing um it's for dominic wrote
the structure the bones of it this is
what we're going to do and then you've
got to
you've got the way dominic directs is
really quite magical and quite
liberating
because it's about creating a near
perfect environment for the performance
to be
free and safe in
and that's down to the crew having a
very very small crew but the right
energy or everybody kind of having this
this vibe together i suppose and that's
really hard to achieve
chris the producer would if you were to
speak to him if ever if anyone knows him
you know talk to him about what
they were trying to just create this
perfect atmosphere
in which we could perform so
it didn't feel um
it just felt like this word is a bit
kind of overused but it felt very
organic but in a good way
tiring though improvising for that all
those hours without a break
it was really tiring um did it just did
it
did it make it does it change the way
you act
because you've written it i mean just
did it feel like
at all no no because i haven't written
those moments those moments are organic
and they're happening there
we have collectively decided we're going
to make this story
and we've spent days and days together
building that structure back and forth
as i suppose in a
in a writer way in a writerly way um
but
when you're there it's about what feels
right and if the camera's rolling and
dominic will be directing a scene and
it might say kirsty goes into the flat
and he might say okay let's not go into
the flat on this one i want you to just
see what happens if you just sit
or have this affect you more or that
affect you so it's
clear it really is about trusting your
director and when you're in those
moments you're
you're not sam you're so in your
character
and if you do trust your director you're
so in that moment that you're not
feeling that you're acting your own
stuff
that way um there's a really striking
thing i mean
having looked at a lot of your work
recently i've noticed that you play a
mother
very often and you did it again here
can you talk a little bit about the um
building the relationship with the two
girls that
played your daughters and you know kind
of how you
um kind of what was the process that you
used with them to get them to relax with
you and to
to work so brilliantly
i think that um there's a
okay i play a lot of mothers because i'm
at that age
and that's they're the roles that are
written for us
men get to be heroes and victims and
all that all the rest of it we don't get
this as as many kind of variation on the
role
as the role written if you get what i
mean i don't mind playing bothers
because i'm a mother
and but that's nature isn't it you know
but there are
people i've played that haven't been
mothers um i think
um i think that
depending on the script you you have a
duty
a responsibility if you can to become
uh to become friendly with whoever
you're working with
if if that's the vibe that the director
wants or that you you you would like
that because some actors just really
need their own space and then
listen i'll see them we'll just get on
with it i find that
really whether you're a child or a 50
year old man or an 80 year old man
i think the stronger the relationship
that we all have
that the safer is on set safe
emotionally because
you're being asked to do things all the
time that are
you know for children it can be
incredibly tiring and it is often
not a very fun place and children i've
got a
funny thing with kids on film sets
because i having been a child actor
all the way back in soldier soldier when
i was i think i was 12 or 13 when i did
that
to to watching children have to perform
some pretty tough stuff
in in films i've done myself i i think
that they need to feel safe with you as
a friend
and and that involves hopefully if the
parents are willing to chat with the
parents
spending time with them offset if you
know with kovid it's going to be hard
but
um listening seeing what they like
um and also i think it's down to the
director on how they direct i think jim
sheridan was extraordinary on
in america because he'd rather just let
them be and get the camera rolling
rather than forcing them into certain
situations where they're kind of
they've learnt their lines at home with
their parents and so they
only know one way to do it and then
you're on set and it's like
what you're really trying to do is to
get
to hope that the child is going to
listen and respond
and still get their lines you know right
ultimately as long as the writer's
comfortable as long as the kids have
been in character and it's all
happening you know we're all good um
you talk there about um you starting
really young did you
and i know obviously you're famously
connected with the central workshop and
that that sort of generation that came
through there can you
think can you remember back to the sort
of
you know techniques and and lessons that
you learnt there
that you've but that you've used
throughout
and also maybe that you see in those
girls that you worked with on
i am kirsty i mean you know can you
remember specifics
i think that i am kirsty thing is very
very different you if you could separate
that for a second because then the
workshop thing is a little bit like
when i talk to actors that went to
either rose brewford or bristol
or rada everyone has memories and
there's a thing that they have that they
bring with them that they learn
or it's a thing i think once you're from
the workshop
um and actually i'm i'm a
i'm a lot older than vicki and i'm those
guys and
jack o'connell i'm i'm a different
generation to those guys
you um
i i i don't know i've often said to ian
smith who used to run
from the workshop and he had it he'd run
it after a woman called sunot
um was that if they could bottle it and
sell it
or give it to i don't know
give it to the world it'd be an
extraordinary thing even from a
a situation to do with trauma or healing
uh
kind of workshop vibe because it really
is a
for me growing up and going to workshop
was
i mean heavy on improvisation i mean
really heavy on improvisation and
character
finding characters and you know kind of
the workshop didn't have just like
everybody was
the same you'd have a funny one a funny
kid a loud kid a very quiet shy
child you'd have a real mix match um
and people often say it's very similar
to anna's shares people that went to
anna's shares in london and the workshop
had
a similar thing going on but nottingham
back then in the 80s and the 70s
you've also got the nottingham playhouse
and you've got this kind of
radical theater happening and you've got
radical
you know certainly for me growing up
with you know kind of the socialist
views that my family held and
very very political so actually looking
back a lot of what ian was doing was
quite political unbeknownst to us
because it was pushing
the boundaries of what kids were were
allowed to do we had an edit suite down
there with cameras we were able to film
each other and
i mean these are like kind of almost art
installations we were doing
on a regular basis he allowed us to
write our own plays
direct our own plays give us the space
um and so you've got the under
at the under 11s the 11 to 16s and the
over 16s group
and they're all meeting for free all the
time
and then he would put on a play whether
it's our day out or
you know um you know winning the willows
or whatever it was but we did
plays and of course shakespeare and and
then it you know when i left back
years ago it then went on to greater and
greater things um
in regards to the level of performance
and plays that they would put on
um but it was just this uh fearless
and it still is a fearless kind
loving safe space for young people to be
um yeah it's like like a mini drama
school without knowing it
but actually with i'm kirsty you left
all that behind and did something
completely different
no but you were talking about the
children yeah were the children
no i do you never leave workshop behind
brian you never
that's in your dna once you've if that's
how you've learned
whether it's bad habits or good habits
that's always in you
and yet it's up to you to as you get as
you change and you get older to navigate
that
but i wouldn't leave my who i am behind
to be i am kirsty but i'm also
those children aren't acting in the same
way as workshop children because they're
not
yeah i may have misunderstood your
question brian i'm sorry no not at all
um
just just getting back to kirsty um
with a with a project like that which is
about such a kind of
you know graphic sort of social issue
it could easily have just the tone could
have been too much it could have been
too brutal too hard to watch how did you
what kind of discussions did you have
about that about um
you know making having giving having
real
impact but also not not having it
something that people
people couldn't turn on and watch that's
a i think that's a dominic
question because he directed it i think
that we didn't have those discussions at
all
did you not no and there's never a time
when you
even when you were kind of improvising
and you know kind of adding
adding the the the depth to kirsty that
you
wanted to do something that use that he
thought no you know what this
that's just too much return off it it
won't work
no that's i'd i that's not how i work
yeah that's a level of maybe that's for
kind of film financiers and producers to
think about when they're
financing projects my job is to
always always be in character it's not
to think about
the manipulation of whether i'm whether
what we're doing is appropriate or not
that
that's a different that's a different if
you like
layer to our industry
but you want people to watch what you do
you want people to
you know kind of take all the things
that you're trying to tell them
yeah but any movie you make or tv series
you make there might be scenes that are
on the cutting
floor and that's happened in all sorts
of
you know and i suppose if you're a
writer that might happen with your you
know your editor or
there's some and that's down for the
editor and the director to
to find out what they feel is the
balance of that piece of art
and at the end of the day if you're
always thinking
you have to think about the audience
because that's who you're making it for
but when you're in that moment
you think about the truth of that i
think
and it's you sh i don't ever come out of
that
world to think oh is this a bit too much
that's that's up that's the discretion
of the filmmaker and then the discord
and then and then it's for the audience
then to decide if they want to carry on
watching or turn off
it's interesting somebody said to me
something about the unloved the film i
made that before i think
first have many minutes nothing is said
and there's an ad break because it's
uh channel 4
and they didn't lose their audience
after the ad break
and i felt so proud of that because
there wasn't it was just very still at
the beginning of that film and i thought
yeah they really
they want to know what happens to this
person and i think that that was the
first time
i'd ever really put that hat on and
thought about that question because
tell us a little bit about getting into
a character
you know kind of how you get into the
mindset for filming i i wonder
i i like probably everybody who's
listening to you at the moment
i listen to your fantastic desert island
discs
when i say listen to i mean wept
throughout i was just absolutely
brilliant
but i wondered music's clearly hugely
important to you do you ever use it to
get into the skin of a role
always and
i suppose it if before acting
a better word i use it to get into the
skin of sound
to heal me to provoke me to get up and
out and about and get my
my [ __ ] together or to dance to feel
better
to music is life
to me and when i started getting
acting parts that meant i was like in
every day
on the schedule it became very
apparent to me that i didn't cope very
well with noise
on set um
on busy busy sets on telesets where
back in the day you know people are
smoking and it's just really everyone's
chatting about the weekend
and i'd be like i've got a really big
scene to do in a minute i've got to go
and
kill some guy and you know it's a band
of gold days and
and i that's when i first started having
headphones
to take me to a place of uh
neutrality and it wasn't so much about
character then
it started off as like taking me out of
someone talking about whether or not the
roast potatoes were crunching off at
lunch time
and me trying to not it's not like
learning my lines or remembering the
lines but just staying in that moment
because we might have done a scene and
then
we go and job break for lunch and then
you're like we're not going to do my
clothes up now
we've we've done the master and we're
not gonna okay all right stay in it
staying at santa
am i gonna eat lunch i don't know i
don't know i don't think i'll eat lunch
you know to stay in the moment and then
and the music was just for that
just to get me out of here and then as
the years went by
i think the first film i did a playlist
for
was that i really remember actively
going
to my playlist um was
jesus son and before then i'd i'd
have a song that would get me into a
scene but i didn't do a playlist for an
entire movie and it was kathy burke who
inspired me to do that because she did
me a take after we did tom jones
uh this uh tv series and she did me this
tape
and i started using that tape for all
these different performances
i was like oh back in the day
and so that's when it started i think
and then that's been
that is now it that once you do that you
can't
becomes a bit of a crutch and i get a
bit superstitious about it now
and you have other things as well i've
seen you talking about how you have a
smell
for each oh yeah yeah everyone yeah and
that again goes back to sam because that
goes back to memories and triggers so
when i was directing
the unloved i was hiding comfort fabric
softener
in the mum's house because my mom's
house was always my real mum's house was
always really clean and nice
and and it just kind of triggers me back
in a good way to that space and then it
was like i think it was
um tracy again in band of gold
um when this character started earning a
bit more money i was like
oh because i didn't like smelling like
me at work i just felt like oh i'm being
a bit mean
and i was always trying to how do you
because i didn't learn how to act in the
supposed tradition in a traditional way
i was like anything that reminded i was
about to take my jewelry i didn't want
my stuff around me i wanted to
to just get just get rid of all that and
um
so i started not wearing any kind of in
the morning not wearing any
uh mascara or makeup to work and no
perfume and all that
and then when tracy started earning a
bit more money my character gone to
london
i remember buying some fancy perfume and
only wearing it for tracy
and that's when it started and i've done
it ever since
tempted to get you to list all the
perfumes that you've worn all the smells
that you want but we'll come back to
that we've got time
um let's get sort of rewind a bit um
sort of
anyway like kind of back to the
beginning after the workshop but
your career trajectory
was kind of fast track rise really you
did your small
smallish scale of british tv you did a
couple of uk indies then you crossed
over to
the states did a picture got an academic
academy nomination you know from sort of
doing under the skin
through to woody allen in just a few
years that seems like a really
fast move did you realize the enormity
of that at the time i mean
did you did this seem like a sort of
logical progression
or did it take you by surprise
not really because i think the thing
that was really for me that was
kind of um like
um scary
was doing my first play uh so leaving so
i left london at 16
and sorry left nottingham at 16 to come
and do this play
at the royal court and i'd know where to
live nowhere to stay and i was sleeping
at that point i'd slept at the
same pancreas train station and a friend
had given me
um the name of someone that she knew
back in the day
who lived in london they worked at abbey
road this woman called dee an amazing
woman
and she lived in the peabody buildings
and i called it convent garden i didn't
think it was coffee
because i went to coffin garden and i'd
like phoned this woman i couldn't get
hold of her and i was like oh
i don't know just turn up so i remember
sleeping you know
in i mean it was really rough obviously
back then
um i'm not i wasn't homeless but i just
had nowhere to go that night when we
slept at the station
and then i remember going and i'd fibbed
i'd said i'd got somewhere to stay so i
could
you know eventually and i got this part
in um a play called ashes and sand
uh that ian rickson directed with uh
susan lynch
and melissa wilson and rachaela
and there was uh nick reading it was
just
anyway amazing cast and i was just like
a play
a proper play i was like absolutely
you know petrified um
and to everything else after that
was a doddle like just you go in the
audition i mean you can't remember as
well for every part you get
remember all my little diaries of like
going on the tubes and all this in
london or
going to new york or whatever it's like
there'll be loads i didn't get
there's a lot of disappointment i
remember being like
you know there's like there's a group of
us that i really really adore and back
then we're all up for the same parts a
lot
he's a really amazing woman like anna
freel
and kelly mcdonald and really really
good women who
were brilliant and so we'd all be up for
the same parts about oh she got that one
i got this one she got that one i got
this one she got like you know
and it was this i mean looking back it
was a really beautiful time and so it
wasn't just that you get everything you
go for and everything's super successful
you're just lucky to be working really
lucky
and you don't think at the time that
it's these
but it is success you're just working
and i'm really happy to be working and
i'm happy to be tr i love traveling you
see so
if for parts in israel i'll go if back
in the day for parts in
i don't know barley i'll go anywhere i
was like yeah just get my backpack and
go i really
yes i didn't i didn't think it sorry if
that sounds a bit
weird i think i'd had my first fear
factor and everyone else was a laugh
after that just go back to that fear
factor you're not
known for doing theater no i
mean we know you did it right at the
beginning but you don't do it now
what's that about um i did two i did a
couple of plays and i used to do like
rehearsed readings and and again like i
remember doing one
for i think it was patrick marber and
then i didn't get the part and i was
really gutted i think anna free got that
part
she was amazing closer she was
extraordinary
and it was it was like you it wasn't i
didn't want to
i just got other parts and then
i had a child quite young and then i had
and then if i was going to be a single
mum working
i had to pay for child care and
i got a mortgage really young and i was
like oh
and i had no support or backup with like
i saw the bank of mum and dad so i kind
of had to stay where i was going to get
a bit of
money would you think about going back
to it
absolutely and even more so when when
knockdown happened i suddenly got this
big
because i i've moved back to the uk and
um
like properly back to the uk um and
i don't know it was this because it
didn't go away it when you when you love
something like that it never goes from
you it's there
i've still got my script from with ian
rickson and he taught me a huge amount
that i just
kept on with and i think stuff from mac
stafford clark i didn't ever work with
him but just stuff that
i use every script i get i use the
things that
ian taught me back then ian smith andy
and rickson
and uh and then obviously filmmakers
teach you things different people that
you work with and you're just always
getting more
if you like tools for your tool bag as
an actor so
i hope you know if i can afford to
but i would i mean now it's like it's
the
you know we just pray and i hope and
pray that we have a theater to go back
to
you know more than ever i mean it just
seemed like i just suddenly had this
heartbreaking moment in a little in
a way that maybe older actors might have
thinking well i ever do a play again
me going gosh will i ever do that again
um
yeah i hope so okay don't bring it down
right now
it's all gonna be great it's interesting
looking at your
looking at your filmography you more
than more than
more than any other actor i can think of
you seem to really be able to balance
that kind of big scale
you know the big scale hollywood you
know academy award
nomination etc etc with very small very
very independent pieces so for example
you did
i think minority report you know
spielberg tom cruise in the same
period year or two years that you did
more than caller
did were you ever counseled against that
kind of
you know veering back and forth i mean
are the people around no
no no but what did happen was very very
early on
living in new york a lot you know this
back in the day there's a lot of
interest in you and you get a lot of
offers and you get a lot of
incredibly um lucrative offers and
but they don't nothing comes for free in
this world you know
it's uh some of these meetings back then
were about i mean i would be given a
part that was a huge part of opposite a
huge hollywood actor
of the leading lady and i'd be all
excited and i think yeah i'm going to do
this one this is going to be great and
there would be a suggestion of me
wearing a skirt to the dinner with the
studio execs that evening
and i wasn't told to wear a skirt but it
was a gentle subtle suggestion
because i i back there you know we're
talking late 90s
97 98 i'd be wearing jeans in a little
jacket and i was very
you know no makeup and and i was just
like
i would literally just tell people to
[ __ ] off
because i'd rather go back to nottingham
and and maybe do
you know devise a play or or go and
write poetry and live in bali for a bit
[ __ ] it i i didn't want that i knew very
early on that that wasn't okay
and that they were compromises that were
weird it was just weird it wasn't like
if if the character needed to wear a
skirt yeah let's put a skirt on if
that's right
but for sammy going to dinner
to kind of seal the deal or have a chat
about
you know all those things with the
leading man i was like nah that's not
cool so i had a few incidents
like that and i also had a few incidents
where
friends of mine were very successful but
i'd made friends in hollywood
and they were really successful they are
really successful and i looked at
elements of their life
and i thought i don't know if i could do
that i really don't know if i could
compromise so many aspects of being me
and that's what i thought there was a um
like a payoff
not you know something just didn't feel
right and then i had my daughter esme
really young
and then that was more um there was more
of an impetus for me to be true
to myself if that made sense so you know
if scripts came through regardless of
their budget if i didn't understand the
script i'm not going to do it regardless
of who the director is if i won't read
the script and get a sense of it
um and then
gosh even if they're not offered i'm not
when i say i'm not going to do it these
things might not be offers to me or even
auditions they're like they're being
sent to me and i'm like i don't want to
pursue this particular role because i
don't understand
hey why they're making it be the role
what this all about
you know you know and then these films
go on to make millions at the box office
and
my agent was like you could have played
that role and i'm like well you know
it wasn't meant to be but the the reason
why i think
um i mean even now i i said to my agent
the other day i said i just i'm
desperate to do another little
little another film where there is an
independent film because
they're few and far between and i get
the privilege and the honor of working
with
a director that is that's making their
vision um being supported by a producer
that's supporting their vision and
that's
that type of cinema i think is getting
rarer
and rarer and you have brilliant
hollywood actresses
and actors that are moving into that
that they often did a bit both but now
they're just totally
doing those films so they're just few
and far between a getting financed and
be
you know being available to me
and it's just it's like it's my dream
and i had a conversation with an actress
on a tv series not that long ago we were
having a really tough day and it was one
of those like turn up get on your mark
we've got
you know we've got five pages to shoot
today and i was like
and she said well that's why i do
theater because i get my
you know i get my weeks of rehearsal and
then every night we can just play in it
and i was like
but this is i love what i do and i love
being on set i love the
magic of watching how the camera works
of
understanding how to perform for the
camera
of of that like oh the magic
it's just movie magic i love it um
go back to mormon caller tell us about
the relationship
i remember seeing you at that time um
actually in a in a
rehearsed reading from more than caller
with lynn
and lyanna the late leona domini and
you read a section from the book um
and you and liana and and
lynn seemed a really tight unit you know
it just seemed to be your kind of happy
place
and you were all kind of um you know
anarchic and anti-establishment and sort
of doing things your way
presumably that was the spirit when you
took on that project
tell us about making that if you can
remember
the experience of making remember that
it said something i remember for the
rest of my life it was beautiful
in a similar way to making under the
skin with karen adler
and i i had a a thing that it was just
so excited to be
being in a room with a woman to to see
what she was
and i loved rat catcher and gas my
doctor shorts and gasman and um
i just i just and also she's she's from
glasgow my stepdad was from glasgow
there was just something it was like
there
was something about how she communicated
she spoke to me like i was clever nobody
at all had spoken to me like i was
clever
in regards to directors they weren't
rude to me
no one was ever rude to me but they were
just busy busy doing their thing and
then i was busy doing the acting but
lynn
spoke to me like a collaborator and i
was only i was really young
but she spoke to me like i had a brain
and i liked that
and she would explain to me composition
and she said i wanted to see this film
and this film and so she educated me as
well
so rather than keeping her keeping her
talents herself
it was like i'm gonna i want you to be
good for me and it was this empowering
a woman empowering another woman young
woman
to be good and i just that was just in
in liberating
you know because it was like she had she
didn't just have a secret it was like
i'm going to share it with you
and so she'd do things like come and
look at this and come and look at the
monitor and
and she'd go and be more of them and go
look at this isn't this beautiful and
then she'd get
so excited about light and
and i was like going it just salivating
at this
human being taking such joy in their
craft
that it was just intoxicating and so it
wasn't that we were anti-establishment
at all we we were just doing our thing
and then in the same way lynn hadn't
worked with like
she'd work with non-actors and even
though i'd done a lot of acting since i
was 12
i wasn't from a traditionally trained
acting background as well so
it it was i just thought it was a bit
perfect
and it was a you know i'll treasure it
those are those memories because you
know
they're few and far between and can you
talk a little bit about that character
because she's a really interesting
character because she's sort of
she's in a way she she should be very
hard for an audience to kind of grasp
hold of her she's
she makes choices that we might not make
and you know you had to bring an
audience with you did you
did was she hard to play um
no i don't think anyone's hard to play
you just play them
you just you literally get on with it
like washing the pots or
you've got something to do you just do
it um days are hard when
you're tired days are hard when you know
you might have lost the light or days
are hard when
you know you lose a location but playing
a character for me is
i don't really think of them as
characters when i'm in it it's in
hindsight you go oh that was that person
and that was that person and that was
that
but i don't psychoanalyze them i don't
beca i just be
it's really hard to describe are you
confident in your performance like at
the time or afterwards i mean do you
watch back what you've what you've
done no not for you no not for years i
didn't watch anything
and i can't watch i can't watch myself
at work
which was really hard when lynn was like
this come and look at this or
you know playback and stuff like that i
don't i don't do that
because for one i i've got i don't like
the sound of my own voice or i don't
like
my big forehead or i've got problems
with my teeth
and but i actually like myself more now
i'm older
because i look i'm getting to look more
like my mom it's weird as you get older
in it and i look and i go i look like
pam that's not bad i love my mom
oh that hello pam looking at my face
but being other people is really weird
um
so no i i i don't really and then my uh
husband uh said to me have you ever seen
any of these things i said well
sometimes you have to see stuff because
you you know obviously you're an adr
and you have to get do your voice stuff
and
sometimes you have to sit through a
screening at a festival and it's
it's hell it's just hell but what i
wanted to do with certain filmmakers is
watch their work after we've done it so
i'd give it a space
and time and then i'd watch michael
winterbottoms film or lynn ramsey's film
or
charlie kaufman's film or spielberg's
film and i watched their film
not my performance but their film and i
was like oh that was a good one
i was in that good film we can tell you
they were all good it's all fine
talking about charlie kaufman and lynne
and you know harmony corrine and david
cronenberg there's a sort of through
line in some of those directors i
suppose you might call them like kind of
extreme
auteurs you know there's a very that you
there's a very specific thing you get
with those directors
do you think you i mean did those to
what extent did those projects just come
to you
accidentally it's another good script
it's another good project or were you
seeking
out working with a particular you know
particular kind of identity
in your directors
i'm just really lucky if i get to work
with directors like that
i don't i mean i how did you know i
remember writing to
a director once just once and i heard
nothing back
that was david lynch and my agent my
amazing agent
uh who i've had two agents for many many
years um
and she said hey you should you know
just why don't you try it
and i did and i heard nothing and i was
selling but i was mortified
and i was like thank goodness i didn't
write to gym drama sure there were all
these people
because you know hopefully one day they
might think always i've got a part for
this person is she busy
and i'll be like oh um
but i think it's down you know it's
casting directors doing
good good jobs i think if they're
allowed to they're allowed to kind of
because you've got so many things about
box office and
you know who's a name and who's not and
sometimes people that aren't right for
roles play roles that they're not right
for
and that could might be said of me i
don't know but i think that
i don't seek that out bryony i just want
to work
and i want to work with people that got
good stuff and hopefully we have a chat
and we get on and
um and my agents are really good they're
like they know what i like and they know
that i'm
i'm looking to work with you know
filmmakers all over the world
male female low budget big budget i'll
bring it on i've just done american
television which was amazing which i was
petrified of
and that was life changing and i'm
really glad i did that because
i everyone said it was the heart it's
just so hard and you know if you can do
that and i was like well if i can do
this i could do anything
it's another string string to my bow so
yeah um when
when you thinking back on working with
those particular directors
when you then came to be a director
yourself with your
debut the unloved did you you know what
can you were you conscious of bringing
particular things from particular
directors to yourself on set and what
kind of director were you
uh i think it's interesting you asked
that because i
my one of my i loved i've had loads of
different incredible experiences on set
but
one of my favorite things about being on
set sometimes is when directors like it
very quiet
and they don't want too many people
about almost like a closed set
and you know when everything you know
what's that ready a nookie scene
i like it when there's no one about and
i like rehearsal
i like to sit in the space with the
director and the writer potentially in
the cinematographer and go what are we
doing here what's going on
and have time with the other actor
before and just talk through the scene
and and if we're lucky enough to have
that time because
you know set time is money and all that
and that's
that's my joy so when i approached it as
a director
i i just said to the crew listen i want
everybody to be able to do their job
um i don't want anyone to feel that
they're in the way and that they're not
allowed to do their job however
this is going to be really intimate and
really really just very small
and quiet um not always quiet because i
play music
as well a lot in between takes and i did
that to just
so the kids were relaxed and stuff like
that and and it was fun for them
um and all i could do was bring my
sensibility as an actor because i'd not
directed before
and the other stuff you when you're in
the moment you can't think oh
what would steven spielberg do well
steven spielberg's got the money for a
60-foot technocrat and i've not got the
money for a 60-foot techno crane
so i've got to try and improvise i think
how am i going to get that shot and
you know it's you to me the prep was the
most important
making sure i had enough prep for all of
the crew and myself
and and um and spending the time and the
money there
and and learning
after all these years that what makes a
production
go smoothly and sometimes what makes
things
you know sadly makes a production have a
hiccup
um and trying to my best to as much as
you can
learn from that and a lot of rehearsal
for the actors
if they had the time to give me that
do you as when you're an actor do you
like rehearsal
yes yeah a lot not not it doesn't always
have to be the scene to be rehearsed
but i like the idea of a huge amount of
discussion
prior to setting foot on that set
and again you found an incredible young
girl to work with
molly windsor who's just so like well
shaheen found
out we've gotta put that one out there
thank you that is but you've got the
best out of her
can you talk a little bit because that's
a really difficult role that she had to
to play you talked about
the total silence at the beginning of
that um
of the film um can you talk a little bit
about
kind of how you as a director thinking
back to you as an actor
had a kind of duty of care to your young
performer i mean were there things that
you you know what kind of what kind of
conversations did you have with her
so she's a child it was conversations
with beth
her mum so molly was really young then
and there was one scene she did with
robert carlisle where it was a
kind of a very wide shot and he comes in
he's interrogating her and he throws her
on the sofa and she was in bits
said we got it we don't need to go again
and in my version of the storyboard i
had
various shots and i had angles and it
was this is what i wanted to do but
there in that moment i thought we got it
you don't need to go again
and that's trusting that and trusting
because i don't like watching a monitor
so because it messes with my head so i'm
always watching the set i'm always
watching the actors
and um as opposed to sitting in a room
watching a monitor of what the camera is
doing
um and i just like to
look in the camera and i like to trust
the operator
you feel that feel that and i think in
regards to molly
and the other children um
it was and lauren soccer as well have to
say that she was extraordinary
and is extraordinary um
listening like did you like that do you
want to go again what could do
anything that felt eggy or you know how
did you know and then
you can feel truth you know what i mean
you you can feel when it's
when you're in that room you can feel
when it's
you know and then you've got i was lucky
enough that we're filming and nottingham
so the broadway cinema because i
shot on film able to watch our rushes on
film
it's extraordinary and i was able to
look at all the rushes and go because
when you're shooting on film as well
it's very expensive so you're not going
to
shoot too much you know so i was lucky
enough to watch and go right okay and
learn a little bit as i went along going
oh i did too much there that was too
much
and next time i'm doing a scene similar
to that i know
really what's important it's interesting
because
you also you had a lovely co-writing
relationship with tony grisoni for that
one
oh my gosh one of the things that struck
me about
the character of molly as you'd written
her was that she was quite
um her dialogue is very minimal she
doesn't say that much
and i was struck because actually you've
often
you've often performed in roles where
you don't say much i mean famously you
got an oscar nomination for one of them
where you literally are
a mute person and the beginning of more
than caller there's no
dialogue there's nothing it's just
there's you don't say anything
so it's interesting that you it's almost
like you trust
me yeah i just want to interrupt you
there because i think the idea of mute
is
fascinating and saying you're talking
about
words that film used to be silent
and so you can say a huge amount with
your body language with your eyes music
the soundscape that a director might
choose to use
so actually hattie in sweden lowdown was
a right chatterbox she was just mute
she was so animated she wasn't a still
person at all she wasn't
quiet she wasn't pretty out there
she was like a silent movie star who
acted with her eyes and her
then there was a scene where she was
playing a silent movie star
but hattie as a person and i think we
have this
you know i i find it fascinating
thinking about
the senses and i find it fascinating
thinking about you know the fact that i
spoke you know don't
say very much there's a lot going on
it's whether the camera
is capturing the thoughts and and the
you know the music and the atmosphere i
suppose all coming across
i hope that makes sense
i'm saying that not all these people are
quiet and molly character lucy
and the unloved is obviously
experiencing a huge amount
she's just not vocalizing it with words
so there's a
she's saying a huge amount but not
i am in pain oh [ __ ] off your bastard
whatever it is literally
there's so much going on that you can't
write words for those scenes and
sometimes that's
the the joy in that is is what isn't
said is just as important as what is
said
and having a shot of an actor listening
to another person is sometimes just as
important as the shot of the actor
talking
um i want to talk about telly quickly
before we get to some audience questions
okay um i mean let's just
cut straight to the walking dead because
i can't resist not doing that
um tell it's about you're you play
another mother
slightly different one this time um how
seriously
did you take on this character i mean
how
in in one sense she's a kind of cartoon
of horror you know ripping
people's skin off and rubbing blood in
her hands and
you know behaving like such a such a a
horror character like how how much it's
just big though
she's not what she's not a big she
doesn't have grand
gestures she was putting the blood on
her hand so that the
zombies can't smell her yeah yeah
absolutely but how much did you when you
when you got offered that part
you know how much did you think of her
as a character as opposed to just
another kind of
you know horror action um
you know silliness like how because
no i don't think it's silly at all like
i think the walking dead is an
incredibly serious piece of
i mean it's all shot on film and if you
go back to the season i started in
season nine and season one started off
and people that may have started with
the show and then didn't continue
because it just goes on and on and on
they should not just saying they should
you know pick it up again it's um
i read uh first of all read the scripts
and thought gosh these are like
this is like a movie and i you know
growing up in the 80s and
i loved kind of george romero films and
i love films like the omen or the entity
or you know um the exorcist
and and you know all of the zombie films
at that time and even that assault on
precinct whatever
the name of that one but you know
there's a there's a time
and that is what the walking dead is
like classic american cinema
and it's shot incredibly beautifully and
they spend
i hate to say this they do spend a lot
of money and everything not everything's
cgi so these
you have greg um who is a director and
special effects but i mean the makeup is
extraordinary we're talking kind of
the most extraordinary makeup and and as
an artist that is
is is brilliant it isn't comic book like
oh how can i describe it it doesn't feel
camp when you're there and everything is
and i think
alpha is one of the greatest roles i've
ever played and i'm incredibly proud of
of not only um the writers that wrote
her because you obviously have a lot of
different writers writing the character
um you have angelo who's a female
showrunner you have a lot of female
directors on the show and a lot of
female writers
um and i was so proud that the main
central if you like villain for such a
show
was a woman because whenever growing up
i'd watch the bond films i wouldn't want
to be a bond girl i always wanted to be
the villain and i was like oh
and then obviously as an actor you hope
one day a script is going to come in
where you get to play
that villain and it just isn't there so
when this came through
um i i was i mean i've been offered
american television before but you look
at the
expectations of you as a human being is
to relocate with your family for seven
years and
you're not guaranteed the episodes and
there's a lot of things that
if any actors are watching this out
there you'll know about or you'll go
it's a risk in a way an amazing risk but
you
you know i i was i've always kind of
been scared of
of getting it wrong um and this was like
a
just a role of a lifetime and i'm like
hold on a minute i'm
you know i was just so proud and and and
i do take it very seriously
and i think that she's actually a very
still character alpha if you've ever
seen any of it or if you're ever
interested it is a different genre for a
lot of people they might not be
interested in it
but you'd be really really surprised i'm
incredibly proud of it
yeah i'd agree with that completely um
did you have anxiety about going into
something i mean
the show's been going for you know 150
episodes or something
um did you have and some of the original
characters are still in it or one or two
of the original characters are still in
it did you
did you how did it feel to kind of go in
presumably it's like a family
of some description did you feel anxious
about going into that world
going into those i felt okay i felt that
i felt
anxious that how long they take to shoot
an episode
how long do they thought about that i
think it's like nine days between five
and nine days
and that's film and that's a lot of
coverage a lot of actors a lot of stuff
um but they're like an incredibly
well-oiled machine and you
you know so long as you know your stuff
and you're ready to rock and roll
you you it's like you know the missing
piece makes the big o the shell
silverstein
i i arrived there and i just felt i just
felt
amazing i felt supported and i miss them
all terribly actually
i'll get emotional thinking about it
because they they do become a family
and it maybe that's what it's like being
on a soap i don't know i've never been
in a soap but
do you know at the point when you took
this on how long the ark was supposed to
be or is that something
yeah yeah okay yeah yeah they they told
me she
she she's not gonna live very lucky okay
and in a way that was like a a
liberating thing that
you're not kind of because what if i'd
have hated it i mean i didn't
i loved it but what if i didn't enjoy it
and when i'm saying to my family
like sorry guys we were here for a few
more years over playing albert
and i loved it so actually i was sad
when
she had her head chopped off but then i
was a ghost in a couple of episodes so
you never know
it was all a bit like yeah she came back
from the dead
and also i was doing harlots at the same
time so i was back and forth
playing margaret wells in harlow's which
was extra so it was like
you know i feel so blessed because i was
i mean what great characters to be
getting your teeth into yeah that's like
wow was that an acute
um exercising the demonstration between
the uk industry and the
us tv industry well no at that point
who uh harlots as obviously it's made by
monumental which is a lovely group of
women and um
so we've got allison carpenter who's on
the you know the producer on the ground
who's amazing
and then um and then you've got maura
buffini
alison newman who and then you've got
other writers there
and then female directors and a
brilliant cast leslie manville
and you know just you know and lyft
highlights it's amazing cast and then
and then i just i was like the cat who
got the cream i have to say because then
i'm off
and that's hulu sorry brownie that was
my point that hulu were funding that so
it's an american
show and it was huge in america i'd be
like going down the street in georgia
and my husband would make me laugh and
i've got a bit of a cackle and um
yeah it was like somebody goes is that
margaret wells and i'd be like oh my
gosh
whereas in the uk people hadn't seen it
sadly until the bbc
bought it put it on and it's like i
think season three is on now and it's
like
yeah so i was i was very lucky okay
we've got some good questions coming in
can we get to that okay um okay so amy
forest wants to know
uh it's probably quite a broad question
she says but how do you prepare for an
audition what's your process
um i used to
um i i'm rubbish at auditions if i'm
honest and um
i tend not to do that but when i was
younger and i was auditioning
um i'd just be try i mean i think it's
harder for people now with having to put
themselves on tape all the time and then
you don't hear back
and you don't know you know you're not
getting any feedback as
from somebody directing you saying can
you be more this or that and i come from
a time where luckily for me a casting
director or a director would be
directing me in the auditions
and i was always i suppose for me
auditioning it was always about being
completely off the page
never not knowing my lines and unless
obviously had literally just been given
them for whatever reason because
sometimes people were quite
um secretive about the pages
um and just being as comfortable in my
own skin and my own
ability to to have a take on it because
ultimately sometimes i think that's what
directors want
they want you to have a sense of what
you're going to do
rather than just going you know what do
you want it's like no
what are you going to bring to this
um adam frist wants to know he says he's
a recent drama school graduate and is
interested in how conscious you are
if at all about the technical aspects of
acting on camera
when the director calls action
okay so it used to be that i would try
and shuttle that off and actually
sometimes i have my fingers in my ears
when they're doing the clapper
board because i hear it ringing for a
very long time afterwards since i asked
for a quiet tap
um i'm just i'm always
the more you do the more aware you are
of
of if something's gone wrong and you
need to redo it or the director what the
director needs or
you know performing and then in the
corner of your eyes somebody will be
saying
you'll know that something's gone wrong
you know we need to cut you know i
suppose it's just time and experience
but
i don't know at drama school if they do
enough on film acting because it is
entirely different i believe
and television acting to to kind of what
people do on stage in a way but that's
my opinion
um question from nick
how do you feel about the editing
process in the sense that it affects
your performance on screen do you ever
think about it when you act
yes i do now i didn't used to and i
certainly don't
on film i think with television
you know that a lot of the time there's
a
formulaic approach to how things need to
be edited to get a story across
and how that's going to work and whether
it's going to cut together or not so i'm
always aware of it
but not so much that it bothers me i'll
be watching how a director might set up
a shot and be going is this going to go
together are we sure
and then the director might be asking
the script supervisor and i'm like
okay yeah and i think when you've been
doing it as long as i have you
those things are just kind of second
nature but on a film
you hope that the editor
gosh they can they can manipulate your
performance to something absolutely
extraordinary or
they cannot understand what you were
trying to do and you're like oh they
that silence was there for a reason and
you've just got it out and
but it's you have to let go of that when
you've done your performance then it
belongs to
the post-production process of the
director and the editor and then it
belongs to the audience
um somebody who hasn't but their name
says how does working on a long-form tv
series like harlots or the walking dead
differ from working on a film
is having to build a character over a
longer period of screen time more
difficult
no it is the same thing and i really
mean this you so long as you know your
character
as in you've got the the essence of that
person
whatever they write for you whatever you
know you
you can be that unless
you somebody's written something that
you so fundamentally think is bizarre
and then you might if be in a position
if you're lucky enough to have a
really respectful conversation with the
creatives and say are we sure about this
is this because in long-form television
the the people making the show have a
lot of story lines and threads that they
need to
balance and they will also have a lot of
things that aren't related to your
character so they need the right things
to go on and so sometimes it's not
personal but they might need something
to happen in order to balance something
out here and there
and you just have to as long as you
you've got your character you just
go with the flow in in film you you're
in the fortunate position to have your
script
hopefully well in advance and if you're
shooting out of sequence
um you'll have prepared your script
enough to be
okay with that that you know where
you're going to be at any point because
they might drop you in at this scene and
and that's going after that and so it is
it is different
in regards to the practicalities and the
legit the logistical
process of filmmaking but fundamentally
and here it is exactly
the same
emily bennett wants to know what's the
most helpful piece of advice or note
a director has ever given you a director
oh my god is gonna say another actor um
you can give us the other actor
oh oh chrissy rock don't let the
bastards grind you down
because sometimes a director will be
telling you to do something and you're
like
i'm doing it i'm actually doing it
they're just looking at a monitor that
big and they can't see what i'm doing
and i'd be thinking
you wait you wait till you get home and
you're looking at it like that i'm
giving you pain i'm giving you
sadness and you just
you just live and learn through that but
um the best advice
oh
i don't think anyone really gave me
advice it was just chrissy rock gave me
that advice
we should all live by that advice um
michael cannon wants to know when
working with a director you haven't
worked with before
what does the process of building trust
look like between you
and them and how does that change once
you work with them again
well in television you're working with a
lot of people that come in
and direct an episode and and i think in
those scenarios
my job is to play either margaret wells
or
alpha just talking about two recent
performances
uh to the best of my ability and let
and in those scenarios sometimes the
directors really are directing
camera and they're directing a scene and
the story
and i think directing episodic
television is slightly different to
let's say what lynn ramsey might do
where she's directing her movie
her film her actor and
you just have to be supportive if for
someone like me at my age now
i just want to be there to be helpful
and supportive
because it's really hard coming in on a
tv show and going like all these people
know each other been working together
for ages
i've got this idea this is what i want
to do and you just
you just try and be as supportive as you
can really
and in those scenarios i just have to
trust that i know
my character enough to just get on with
it for wanting a better word
but if i'm lucky enough to be on the set
of let's say tom beard when i did two
for joy who was his first feature film
um that trust has to be there when we
first meet
because i and that will decide if i'm
going to do that job
and when we meet and i feel safe that he
has got the right
instincts and he comes from a good place
then you have to trust and you just have
to give it 150
even that even if that person's never
directed a movie because that's what's
going to
you that togetherness is going to get is
what that process is about
um martin vaughan wants to say sam
you've done nottingham proud
uh question is you've been a part of
some groundbreaking tv over the years
both as an actor and as a director
what was the tv that inspired you
growing up
okay so i watched growing up i watched a
lot of like neighbors and home and away
when i got in from school
but if we're talking about the things
that made me go up it was ken loach
it was seeing abigail's party on the you
know
i think it was play for today or you
know um
but when words like inspire we knock
them around now
we live in a woke society and all that
you know back in 86 87 no one's asking
you're not being inspired you just know
what you like and what you don't like
and i was never one for enjoying when i
was younger musical theater
you know i could i really liked danny
the film the john houston film but then
i'd watch another musical
not like them i didn't know why but i
didn't i was always funny about
if things were fake i knew very from a
very young age i didn't like
phony not the phone is bad
i didn't like that that world
i liked the alan clark world i liked the
ken loach world i seemed to
it seemed to make sense to me because it
was truth
uh oliver scott gil glieber wants to
know how you work on your accents
especially alpha's american accent
you've got a lovely southern accent
um accent work is i find really hard and
i have to do a lot of work on it and i
have to put the prep in i have to put
the time in
and i work with different accent coaches
if i'm lucky and that might be
just to do a session before a movie
where i go i'm playing this part
can you work with me for a bit and i
will just
get um uh
you know voice exercises and they will
help me out with taping it i'm not very
good at understanding what they talk
about with diphthongs and how you do
things with
vowels and all that i'm like i have to
listen i have got what they say
luckily i've got an ear but that doesn't
mean
it's easy i just have to i need to know
it
where i don't just know the lines i know
the i know the character i know the
voice
because because you've got to know the
who the person is before you can do the
voice because the person is about breath
how that person breathes and
you know sighs or walks and moves it's
all connected to them
then it goes back to the voice so it's
not just about hey i'm doing a geordie
accent how do
i manage whatever stupid thing like that
it's bigger than that
and it takes a huge amount of commitment
and
and dedication and just hard work
you know
can you hear me i think we cut off
kylie conklin wants to know yeah yeah
yeah we got you
um kylie
okay one last point on the voice thing
as well i think i worked with a woman
called
lyleen mancell when i was young it's my
first american accent
and up until then i'd always just gone
to a place with a little dictaphone and
recorded how they sounded whether it was
bradford in band of gold or
i went to county antrim for my first
film this is the sea
richard harris and mary mcgreen directed
that and
and just i would just listen and copy
and i was i was so scared to work with a
voice coach
in case something changed in me that i
wasn't real but actually
getting the right voice coach and doing
all that work is i can't recommend it
highly enough it's
it's brilliant sorry stage fright
stage fright so how do you get over
stage fright nervousness before filming
i mean do you have stage fright
once i had it really badly once um and
it was horrific and that was actually
anxiety that's a panic attack
and i do suffer with panic attacks and
anxiety and i think that's kind of my
stuff that's my own stuff that i can
bring
to my work environment i ask myself
questions am i sleeping enough
am i healthy you know what stresses and
what have i got in my own life that i
just need to deal with because
having to turn something on quite
quickly all the time
and being you know that's hard
and i was doing the cronenberg film and
i was in this limousine and i had this
monologue i think it was like a 20-page
monologue
my character had and it was bizarre and
it was
you know in the the crew were having to
shake the car
because there was a riot going on
outside and i literally just kept
forgetting my lines
but that was also the first time i'd
worked for a digital camera
and what happened was the camera
kept jarring before i forgot my lines
and so it was just suddenly i was
watching little pieces of my
world kind of fall apart where the
camera went and then
they're shaking the car and then i'm you
know
it was just an awful experience and i
was i took
some herbal things
it was called paciflora and these little
drops
and i started to meditate and i i kind
of
found it again so that was the one and
only time touchwood but
it i think it was me i think it was
where i was at in my life then
um and i deal with ptsd um to do with my
childhood so that was
interesting because that had never
happened acting had always been my
always been my safe space
and all of a sudden i was like that was
weird
i think it was because i didn't trust
the camera it was a new it was a new
energy because i the film camera makes a
noise and even though that's annoying to
people and they're putting coats on it
sometimes i'm bashing it
i love the camera it's my friend and
then all of a sudden there's this little
thing and they were doing take after
take after take after take because they
could and i was like this is just weird
so learning a whole new way of working
um
here's a challenging one james hughes
says the versatility of your credits is
so impressive and you're only halfway
through your career
what are your aspirations for the
industry as we move forward into new
times
and and the roles you hope to play next
it's a bit broad but give it a go no
it's i think it's a good question i
hope that i can direct more that people
will be kind enough to
fund some of the things i have to say um
i hope that i get to play
just for one of a better word juicy
roles really interesting roles
and i hope that they're written by women
as well as men and i hope that we see
more women
uh i want a 50 50 everyone out there
whoever's watching i just want it to be
50 50.
um if possible the right people at the
right times but
you know that would be great um and i
think in these times
uh certainly the times have covered and
moving forward i just want everybody to
be safe
as safe as we possibly can be but we
need to we need to survive we need more
funding from
the government they need to you know
it's outrageous what they're doing and
not
understanding you know how much you know
what they're all doing they're sitting
at home watching their netflix and their
bbc iplayer aren't they in the evening
you know whether it's bake off or
another series or something they're
watching
they're watching us they're watching
people are watching cameramen have done
their work editors have done their work
actors have done their work directors
are directing
you know people have done post it's like
come on so i just pray
and hope that we you know we get to keep
doing this
you've cut again you went all still are
you so very
i'm still here can you hear me now yeah
okay we are in fact out
out of time but i just want to know one
thing you sound so
in a way so joyful about your craft you
you i think you love being an actor um
oh my gosh
dream come true yeah i mean but your
daughter is an actor when she first
when she first you know started acting i
know she was acting in a film with you
but
when she first sort of headed into your
world did you have any reservation did
you
or is it such a joy experience that
you're very happy for her to have that
experience too
um it's a really long answer to that and
you said we'd run out of time
so that's a whole separate thing but i
will say to you
that acting has saved me i feel
fortunate privileged that i was able to
do it coming from a working class
background
and we need drama teachers in schools we
need that to be respected and understood
we need
more funding in that way and we need
more diversity
i mean across the board in in regards to
this amazing industry that we
we're all lucky enough to be part of but
i do have joy
and i i count my blessings and i i still
love it
i still get butterflies even talking to
you now the bafta audience i feel
privileged
to be even the word bafta on my bloody
thing there i feel
unbelievably privileged and we need to
take care of
it and and take care of each other you
know
that's perfect the perfect way to end
samantha martin it has been so wonderful
to hear you talk about
what you do and you know congratulations
on your bafta nomination most recently
and we look forward to many
many more um thank you to everybody who
joined us tonight thank you to all your
questions i'm so sorry that we didn't
get to them all
um and thank you again to see containers
for supporting this event
but it's been a real pleasure and see
you again on screen
soon thank you very much take care bye
god bless bye
you